hey what up losers hey guys i'm ken
fresno oh god that's not the way i
wanted to start this
he's ken for us now um and you are oh
i'm emanuel rodriguez the actor who
plays royce lopez on revenge of the and
boy do we have a special
surprise in store
for our patrons worst kept secret by the
way everyone knew because we gave it
away basically i know we gave it away
but anyway we interviewed
jim brewer and i got to tell you that
was that was a blast [ __ ] dude you guys
are about to see it but i mean we had a
lot of fun
jim rules and i just wanted to say
beforehand look hey
check out his patreon his patreon rules
the guy is hilarious um i'm gonna have
the link in the description of the video
but uh that was the that was the most
fun i've ever had in an hour with my
pants on
i'm just kidding i don't have pants on
patreon.com jim brewer comedy specials
where you want to go uh yeah he's great
so yeah this will probably be on our
patreon for like a month
great description we had jim brewer on
he was funny guys he was he was very
funny shocking hey guys i'm going to
shock you this interview is going to be
funny
we are the people i will say this the
first people to ever get you and brewer
to do a grady dried impression
that is that is true no one's done that
so we got that but now he was he was he
was [ __ ] great um so yeah check out
the interview and uh
tell us how much we suck i guess right
all right cool frozen set give them a
countdown
oh and every
two
one forget it do it what merch
no i was just gonna say and uh hey to
all you velvet rope members all you
non-poors make sure you rub this in the
poor people's faces oh yeah let them
know how good it was let them know they
lost a show this week you got bonus
content and frozen do the countdown
again but start at 21. and say it in uh
chinese
go 21
20.
that's just gingrich
just do the three
three
two
one
what's going on all right now we're
talking what's up man how are you doing
welcome
well i got two of you what's going on
you guys it's two of us right isn't that
crazy yes
it's easier we did get to do half the
work of on our show then i like that
yeah i like that a lot
so how do we want to kick this off yeah
i mean we're not honestly we're just not
used to pre-recording we always do [ __ ]
live on the fly so i'm like usually
people are already listening and then
i'm like oh and here he is and then
we're just going to pre-record all that
so it's like oh hey what's going on
what's up man thanks thanks for doing
this dude we really appreciate it the
this i have to say right off the jump is
um we this is another bucket list one
right yeah absolutely we've had a we've
had a banner year over here so i'm kind
of pumped about this yeah man we're big
fans it's been for a long time don't get
too excited that might suck this is a
lot of pressure i have i've never ever
in 20 years seen you suck on the radio
or on broadcast sir
and that goes back to uh uh i was
thinking of this the other day when you
told me
was coming on
i was thinking all the way back to and i
don't know if you remember this jim um
opie and anthony back in wnew there was
a guy named larry that called in
and it claimed to murder somebody
and it was a whole thing for a whole
weekend they made they made national
news media this squirrely guy called in
and was like yeah i was involved in a
murder and
it literally ended with the nypd going
that guy's out and you just happened to
be in studio that day
and you made that bit you made that bit
because they were just kind of playing
good cop the whole time with this guy
and you were just
imitating him
for like four hours straight and it was
the [ __ ] i love that i'm telling you a
bit you don't even remember you might
need to look up hoping anthony uh larry
the murderer because you'll hear your
own voice on there and it's the funniest
[ __ ] i was thinking back to that the
other day i'm like that's still one of
my favorite bits man
that's so weird i can honestly say i
don't know if it's my age or from uh
cells that were fried in the past
i do not remember that
man it was such a funny bit man i just
yeah i mean yeah i think a little bit
more i mean i we the same thing happens
to us all the time i think people will
always go look dude i loved it when you
said blah blah i'm like i said that yeah
that's pretty funny
well that show man that that
that was a game changer that was um i
mean there were big radio shows before
but those guys they took it to a whole
new level it was um
you know what i owe them
i owe them a lot of credit um it's funny
we just talked about yes
same thing yesterday where they came up
again opie anthony where
those guys made me feel super creative
for just
being who i was which is really just a
fabricated storyteller at the end of the
day
a very good storyteller though i gotta
say but thank you yeah yeah yeah but
yeah man it's it was uh
it's it's funny because um
i i saw what you were you know what you
were doing you know and that's that's
the reason i was like we got it first
off we're in florida
so uh um oh where are you where in
orlando central florida
oh i'm in sarasota right now oh yeah
there you go so you can see well you're
in sarasota tonight right you're doing
the show yeah i'm in sarasota tonight
and head to tampa tomorrow and
i'll probably rebook these
next month sometime in february or
something like that yeah but you're
you're not now you're a florida guy so
congratulations so you're you know thank
you i love it it's pretty cool here
right it's pretty cool it's amazing i
don't feel this is what this is what um
i didn't realize i was missing for a
long time the persona is you come here
and and um
you know
you
you retire and then you go on the beach
and you get ready to die or join a club
or whatever and that's fine
but what i got out of here is a
the freedom of
really not worrying about is there going
to be a mandate are they going to force
my kid to get vaccinated are they going
to force my kid to wear a mask every day
at school every day and this is going to
turn into another depression are we are
the taxes going up or the thing what are
they going to do they're going to go
it alleviates
all that and as much as
most people don't realize it's such a
burden and such a stress i was just up
in syracuse and they're all just scared
to death right now because they don't
know where they're going oh they put
mass mandates on monday which is
ludicrous too because i was there on a
friday and they're like listen
this is so serious
that
we're going to put mask on everyone
starting after the weekend on monday oh
well
okay
least they have our our lives in their
best effort of livelihood
so
with that said
where i'm at alleviates so much of that
the other thing
i'm an outdoor person i love nature i
love it it's the only place where i find
complete serenity and some complete
peace
and
just being able to go outside
and
even just ride a bike it sounds corny
but just to get on a bike i'm not
talking with the spandex and you know my
my hat that's for i'm talking just eight
years old
i'm watching the egret for 10 minutes
the peace of mind is just the peace i
have in florida the warmth everyone's
down here pretty much for the same
reason
and if you already lived here they all
is
you know i
you know people say oh you know there's
areas that are redneck no kidding wait
you ever been to half the areas in
jersey it's no different yeah yeah
they've never
been to south jersey or upstate new york
like there's plenty of yeah exactly is
it's just a different accent your banana
yeah so
i love florida
florida's cool because it's like it's
like three different states in one like
if you look in south florida you know
you got i'm cuban so you get that's
where i'm from originally so you get a
lot of like you know a lot of cubans and
all that stuff but then you go up up a
little higher then you have like you
know all the jewish people live in boca
raton then you go up a little higher to
central florida that's tourist town and
then when you're up in ocala or
pensacola yeah you're those are rednecks
mm-hmm
and it's everywhere everyone's
everyone's coexisting everyone co-exists
here because regardless of what you are
what you believe the one thing i love
about florida even though you know
listen i'm floored my whole life so
they've been making fun of ford since i
was a good oh a florida man oh look all
these dumb people in florida and now i'm
going there laughing at these people
walking into restaurants with like three
masks and going i need five boosters or
you're gonna kill my grandma i'm like
huh i'll take my meth alligators thank
you very much
i got i gotta say too you're gonna get
very very close to uh like
because i'm like you i'm a long island
boy uh and then i made it out to florida
damn going off 15 years ago and i've
been all over florida and i'm just
warning you now the florida man thing
does slowly take over your life in an
awesome way like i'm i swear to god now
i got my concealed carry i'm rocking
flowered shirts with a gun underneath
you're gonna get there i'm telling you
i wear my gun to publix now it's just a
florida thing
i'm not too far away from it
what's what's
what's more fun to think about my wife
is the one that's more into it my wife
is the one going i
[Music]
she doesn't need a concealed carry as
long as it stays in the house or the
glove box just throwing that out there
you can have it that's right you can
have it in the glove box of the house
anytime no permit i love this and it's
kind of cool because we're i'm in polk
county which has grady judd and grady
judd famously during the riots was the
one that was all over the media because
he was like look man this is florida if
someone walks in your door you shoot
them right out yeah he said shoot them
across this was that the guy who did
this he took out the he took out like
pictures and he goes yes this here yeah
that's the guy this is called
this is called a riot
this is called burning things down
being violent it's called a riot
this here
this is a peaceful protest
this is a riot now i don't know what the
rest of the country and your mass media
is trying to portray
what a what a peaceful protest is but if
you come to florida and you do this
you're okay if you come here you will be
arrested for it
he's always we love him because he
always he always comes out with his
pictures like every time he goes up he
is this is one of my favorite thing
because he does a press conference daily
yeah and my favorite thing about it is
in most places they'll they won't really
like people don't want to jump the gun
on anything when somebody's been
arrested you're like well we arrested
him or we're going to let the d.a come
this dude will go on tv and go
this
is marcus jacobs he
drove here to have sex with a
six-year-old child
this guy marc jacobs likes to have sex
with children and you're like jesus dude
like he does not let you slip through
the cracks man you're like oh [ __ ] dude
oh god oh god oh god i'm fired now we
caught him
and my only regret was that we didn't
get to put 180 holes in it
my only result came out with his hands
up but this coward who likes to stick it
in an eight-year-old child
unfortunately has to go through the
system and waste our money still he
doesn't wish he had a pistol we were
aiming but he does say that you're doing
it as if he really does say like so
awesome and my only regret is that he
peacefully surrendered and i'm like
jesus dude i don't think you could they
did unload on a guy that was trying to
hit him with their car remember they all
all of them loaded it was like 47 rounds
into a car
i'm sorry he tried look he came at us in
an aggressive manner the guy got one
shot off at deputies and it was over
it was game over here and we live in a
rural area so they don't mind just
unloading because they're like yeah
we're out in the country
he said that he said that during the
riots too he's like now
if you decide
auntie for whoever and you're gonna go
into my neighborhoods i've deputized
everyone in my county
and they made you and i told them use
your weapons to defend
so if you go in these neighborhoods do
you know they all got guns and i'm
allowing them to use it well guess what
florida didn't have any problems yeah we
were fine we were we were like
immediately we were totally fine you
know a little riff-raff started but they
ended it right away and i remember that
because then i started walking around in
a child's plastic sheriff's badge and i
was going down to the laundry room in my
apartment complex and i was like listen
i'm a deputy now we don't want teenagers
hanging out here at night you guys keep
[ __ ] breaking the machines
get out of here
[Laughter]
sorry about that you're good merch just
menacingly flipping a quarter yeah
walking around dressed like raylen
gibbons
oh [ __ ] yeah man but i mean that's
that's funny because you know when when
we because you know we cover that we do
a show every day so we cover all this
stuff all the time all the crazy vaccine
stuff and i remember when it first
started we said on our show where like
two weeks to flatten the curve i go yeah
talk to me in two years because this is
not going to end and it never does right
it it never ends they there's a new mass
mandate going on right now again i think
in new york again and in la again
but um the when you went out there and
you said look i'm not gonna do any shows
where they make people get vaccinated
man i saw how many people got so mad
because they don't like anybody
questioning their authority they hate it
my yeah my thing was i was amazed at how
quickly
how and this isn't the first time i've
seen it but just when you go on twitter
it's like i was able to tell who thought
jim brewer was funny or who didn't by
whether or not they had their pronouns
in their bio it's all based on politics
now so it was literally all of a sudden
a wave of people going [ __ ] jim brewer
he was never funny that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] he's dead to me when i've never
laughed at jim brewer [ __ ] him and
you're going come on man now you're just
now you're just lying you're just
feeding into the algorithm man like come
on dude
well i'll be dead honest with you uh i
never looked at any of it it was really
i am that's my hand to god so the only
the only thing
i would have other people go
yo keith oberman's an [ __ ] and i went
well no kidding everyone's known that a
long time the guy's like
he's soulless and he's zero he'll sell
his child as long as he gets a uh
another paycheck that guy is clearly
just taking vanity and going
he's a he's oh give me more more
attention more vanity
[Music]
if tomorrow i tell them hey ken oberman
you gotta you're you're now gonna have
to sell uh you know
uh
murdering people okay i'll figure it out
i mean so when people like him
or anyone say anything
i can't i know their world
um i know their what their job is i know
what their characters are i know i know
the system and that bothers them even
more and they say that the most
unthought
unthoughtful stuff see we're in a period
of time where
just because you scream it and you tweet
it
uh they think they're right
um so like for instance you know i
i i don't even know i put something up
and uh i don't know wherever it was my
friend said dude you're hot on twitter
right now i said i don't even go on
twitter why i don't know it's like a big
so what do you what are they what are
they debating about what's going on oh
but and he sent me a little piece that
just you know it said like jim won't
play vaccinate places and then you know
some woman
says amazing how science is fine as long
as it helps his wife with cancer but not
when protecting his his audience jesus
christ i did see that tweet too
that's where
humanity is where someone
will sit there and go first of all
it has nothing to do with science
second of all it has nothing to do with
protection
where everyone loses
their common sense because they believe
what they see what they read what the
tweet is uh what dan rather whoever
their their favorite person is what they
don't realize
is everything being sold to them
is it's not their thought it's just this
is such a clown show
and they don't even know they're in the
middle of it to say
oh
well
the sorry that's not a dude science
i'm telling you
i know rock stars
just look at my history
who i've been around
who maybe i've done music with who i've
been around
this has nothing to do with health it
has to do with
many money
when i have when i have people say you
know
they want us to tour but they want to
vaccinate the whole entire crew and i go
well why well because insurance and
promoters all right so it's not right
there you're just you're not about
health it's the money
you're about money so you're gonna
you're gonna perform
knowing you're gonna force people
and that's on you that's okay if you
convince yourselves about hell if you
truly believe it's about health
then
god all for you
but don't pretend this is about hell and
don't go on the on the soap box saying
we're saving lives and and people like
this woman going oh he doesn't care
about no i am protecting
my audience
because a woman like that i want her to
talk to my friend alex
write to his face and say oh vaccines
are efficient tell him to his face whose
daughter
was paralyzed
the next morning when she woke up as a
child during the swine flu
stick that science up your ass because
you're small-minded
you're small-minded you don't have a
thought prayer tell my friend lou
who after he swears on his life his
child was normal until a certain amount
of vaccines and his child became
autistic in front of his eyes
well he never ran his family and two
other people dude i know the comedy club
owner in new jersey his daughter is
having operations
these aren't these aren't these this is
real life and what's what the crazy part
is operations to the point they thought
it was cancer after she got the shot
and they clearly told her at sloan
kettering that's from the shot but if we
say something the people would come and
to take our license and we must be very
careful dude
i am protecting my audience well they
also they also say it's we're saving
lives they want to save lives they don't
want to lose any lives but they seem so
gleeful every time an unvaccinated
person dies they can't wait to throw
that on the front page and do a victory
lap and they're like look at that
another uh uh local am host and pastor
who didn't want to get vaccinated guess
what he's [ __ ] dead now stupid idiot
and everybody's like clapping like seals
on [ __ ] twitter and you're like okay
so then it's also not about saving lives
right that we don't care we just don't
care
listen um
my friend right now
um i was supposed to fly back to new
jersey on friday
because we were gonna have our
neighborhood and family party with this
group of like we're brothers and sisters
and they sent me a thing today now he's
fully vaccinated he's got he's sick as a
dog
last week uh my friend
tommy he's vaccinated sick as a dog
i know six people
fully vaccinated
so
this is where i just okay so
the sales pitch
is if you get vaccinated
that was the first sales pitch you get
vaccinated you'll be safe okay
all right you might get it but you might
not get as bad maybe you need a booster
oh okay
okay if if
if you get it it's really bad it's
because it's a breakthrough variant oh
okay
hey we got another shot coming okay
okay well this new omicron it doesn't
matter if you're vaccinated oh okay
that is the power of mind control
there's no thought process we've been
trained in the matrix since we were
children and that's where we're at
you're either going to wake up or not
and if you don't wake up i'm not mad at
them
they do need love they need affection
it's like it's like dealing with a a
senile lady he's like hi grant how are
you doing today
the unfox day it's going to kill us i
know shh
let's watch your favorite channel again
but people are dying
[Laughter]
it's funny because we talk about it on
the show it's like look the government's
always done shady [ __ ] like we know oh
name five times they've done shady [ __ ]
like everyone's always the chinese but
at least back in the day they used to
have the common courtesy to lie to us
like they don't even do that anymore
they're now they're just doing the like
yeah and what are you gonna do about it
take it or you're going to the [ __ ]
camps i don't have time for this [ __ ] i
got no more patience yeah i said sorry
sorry listen
when [ __ ] fouchy's on on the news
saying things like my patience is
running thin i'm like i don't give a
[ __ ] what you think at least when they
passed the patriot act into like you
know back in 2001 to 2003 at least the
muslims were on tv they were scary right
like i was way more scared of muslim
terrorists back then than i'm afraid of
kovac now so we fell for it but now it's
like kova's not that deadly and they're
like no we need to spend trillions of
dollars and just fly this economy into
the [ __ ] ground and i'm like what if
we didn't do that though but we have but
now we have a bunch of new billionaires
that would have never been billionaires
if this didn't happen so there's that
and we're gonna have a trillionaire soon
so that's cool
unfortunately um
there there needs to be
answers because
people can talk about it all they want
this is not stopping and it has nothing
to do with
really i in my opinion this is a
full-blown takeover oh yeah and you know
i have certain people that say oh you're
crazy you're this and why would they
want to do it why does anyone want power
why does anyone want another 10 million
dollars why does anyone want a hundred
million dollars what does anyone want
five six homes why does anyone want to
be uh the award for the top ceo why
because of power vanity and ego it's
been the demise of humanity since the
beginning of time and right now they're
just they're going for the purge that's
how i see it this is um and it's
brilliant i'm i i hate giving them
credit but the power of fear has existed
since the beginning of time and today is
no different right back from the roman
empire i was in rome and went wow
the power of fear gee good lord they can
make you do anything
well it's like what somebody said which
i thought was very funny it's like you
know what's the difference with the
united states falling apart and when
rome burned and somebody goes at least
rome had good roads
that's a very good point at least they
had good roads
so
there there has to now come a solution
you know we've been talking about it way
too much now what is the solution and
for me
the solution has been like i said all
the way back to your question
um
that's been the greatest thing that i've
done in for myself i have a peace of
mind
i don't need
to be in places that insist on being
vaccinating all that
i just don't need to be there people
want to laugh everywhere and if they
feel safe and free enough and
you know what is replica i don't
and when you become a society where if
you just throw an idea out or you make a
statement and everyone does a power of
madness what you're teaching everyone
when you go twitter think about this
what do you do
you
you insult
you judge
you
you have no respect for yourself or
others
you're reckless in your words and your
thoughts
would you teach your child to be that
way
i don't know everyone that would teach
their children to be that way but this
is what brainwashing has done to grown
adults that have doctor degrees master's
degrees they've become
demonic savage animals that you would
never want to spend time with
but you're right and you know a lot of
people because we talk about that too
and a lot of people go oh demonic what
are you crazy i'm like is there another
word to describe it like
what else is there right when you want
to control we talk about this in the
show a lot it's like when when you feel
the need that i need to control
everybody else's child i need to make
sure that i'm the pied piper then i'm
i'm the one telling you wear a mask you
know wear a mask and kid here you go
here you go kid that kova wouldn't do
anything to
take a shot and then you know what they
do it's what they do all the time
they'll start normalizing articles will
be like uh it's actually normal for
five-year-old's heart to explode i'm
like no it's not stop lying to me
because every time they get caught in a
lie they tell you uh actually it's
normal that it's not working actually
it's normal that listen we're gonna need
15 shots and at least the the thing i
will say is there are some positive
things coming up because there's some
people that i talk to
that there's a lot of positives yeah
there's people people that i talked to
didn't want to take the the shots but
you know they said you know what i'll
take two that's fine but then you asked
me are you going to take the boosters
like i'm not i'm done i'm done i'm not
gonna keep playing this game i want off
of the carnival right like i went off of
this ferris wheel i'm finished today
amtrak had to take away their vaccine
thing because the employee said we're
not doing it you'll shut down the
service we're not doing it an amateur
goes okay fine we're not going to do it
wow amtrak did it that's biden's
ultimate betrayal he must just that must
be the biggest stab in the past
oh my god not him i lost amtrak
there's no way
no one's left trains more than me god
damn it
this is such a this is such a joke on
humanity in the whole country in the
world you know i'm not i'm not into
politics
but i'll tell you what if i said to you
guys right now okay guys
i moved to florida and i could tell you
this
you know this hurricane season the next
one that comes up
i know it's the best preventative to do
for hurricanes
it's to get vaccinated
i saw them say that
biden said that
the leader of the foreign
you can't tell me people in japan were
going
in order to prevent hurricanes you get
vaccinated
what is going on in america they're
laughing at the world
who looks at that and go is this really
happening and then again the way they
tool everyone is
people go you know it's not right
disrespectful to say something about him
because he's not healthy
exactly
you know it's like if i if i was weird
if i walked in a room and i put a gun to
both of your heads and i said look i'm
taking away all your freedom you're not
allowed to leave this room until you
both get vaccinated
and you look at me and say no and then
jim brewer turns to you and goes hey why
are you messing with my freedoms
it's like no the guy who walked in the
room with a gun to your head is the one
that's [ __ ] with your freedoms and
then they're making you turn on the guys
okay dude if you just listen to him
he'll let us out of here like hey you
know maybe if uh you know maybe he won't
rape us he'll just make us blow him if
if we give him you know what i mean and
you're like either way just no i'm not
doing it and it's the craze this has
been the craziest uh stanford experiment
level [ __ ] i've ever seen yeah and it's
yeah and i mean evil isn't the wrong
word to call it at some point
being a greedy [ __ ] crosses into the
evil realm like there's a certain way
where you take it a little too far like
there's nothing wrong with you know
wanting a little extra and there's
nothing wrong with being a bit
unsatisfied and wanting more that's how
we got to space and build cathedrals and
[ __ ] but it's when you start going like
no
i want everyone in this town is required
to suck my dick once a day and you go
well now you're now you're just power
mad now you're just forcing everyone to
do this humiliation ritual and they're
even doing it with the politic like the
politicians themselves are so
wholly owned by
you know oligarchs and and p you know
shadow power players and stuff that you
had the mayor of new york city dressing
up in next jerseys eating french fries
spinning plates on [ __ ] sticks and
like lori lightfoot coming out with the
census cowboy and it's like you can tell
the people in power
also love humiliating the middle
management that we think is in power
which is why they kind of make them go
on tv and look like [ __ ] because
they're all they're all in their [ __ ]
you know marble and brazilian rosewood
offices
in europe laughing at these people and
going like we got him to dress up in a
[ __ ] nest jesse and he's eating cold
shake shack fries that have been sitting
on his desk for an hour this is
hilarious this is hilarious
they love it
that's when i knew like this is
this is just such a joke on all society
and the ones that don't see it
it's it's
it's alarming
it's sad it's uh it's a little sad and
the worst part is they're the ones that
will
like for instance you've been very
outspoken about your beliefs
if if jim brewer catches [ __ ] covet
tomorrow and dies there will be there
will be parades and victory celebrations
from the left but meanwhile when
somebody and you could ask we've covered
it on our show so many times where
somebody got a side effect from the vacs
we're not taking joy in that i'm not
doing a victory like like if you if you
made your own informed decision to get a
vaccine hey man i i've never once
started fighting with somebody i'm like
hey man i get it you want to travel you
got a job you got a family to support
i'm not going to tell you not to get the
facts and if you had adverse reactions
or died i wouldn't be going haha [ __ ]
facts loser i'd be like oh jesus he died
that's that's horrible man like that's
because that's what a human being does
human beings empathy
it comes it always comes down to fear i
have a friend
um older guy
and this started a couple years ago and
he said you get your flu shot
and i said
no i've never gotten a shot my life and
he said well that's stupid you should
start getting a flu shot
okay and i went so you know i started
getting fired up and i said what do you
what do you
i'm stupid
because i i won't get a flu shot yeah i
mean you know i had the flu and you
don't want it i said yeah you had it
because i see the way you it's what it
you got it wherever you got it people
get sick every september is another flu
and
fever
every holiday
flus and fevers
ago so then
we kept you know then it turned into
even back then this whole vax anti-vax
was already established a long time ago
and would amp up you guys all forget
they already remember measles measles
two years ago oh son the measles are
back wow who would have thought back
from the dead here come the measles get
your measles shot and we'd have people
going coming in going you haven't got
your measles [ __ ] i said i'm not getting
a stupid measle oh god you're
it's the same thing to sit here and i
told him he goes uh
i can't believe you're uh
not vaccinated i went well let me ask
you something so
if you're vaccinated
okay so if i take medicine it doesn't
work unless you take the medicine even
though you're not sick and i'm not sick
do you how did you destroy common sense
in humanity how did you take that little
piece out of the brain that makes no
sense whatsoever here you're shot boom
you're safe well
not unless
the everyone else gets it
what
what
i'm just confused he keeps using this
word uh flu he keeps saying oh yeah i
don't know what that is there's no such
thing as the thing that disappeared last
year look at the numbers the flu doesn't
exist anymore yeah it's wonderful
now everything it's a miracle the flu
actually doesn't exist anymore which is
awesome
it's true though and the thing is like
that's the other problem is you know
if you would have told me i would say
like 10 years ago that this would happen
i go bro look people aren't that stupid
people aren't that dumb but now like the
shocking part to me isn't that the
government did shady things because they
always do shady things right the
shocking part to me
is how many people
immediately just said yes master yes
you're right you are right i can't go to
a dave matthews concert if i don't have
three shots that makes total sense thank
god i'd rather get covered
that's just mean
and not just the government but how much
we bowed to big pharma who i thought we
hated like a year ago right like didn't
we all hate the pharmaceutical companies
two years ago weren't they like evil
[ __ ] money grubbing price gouging
scumbags and then all of a sudden it was
like oh no you guys are all heroes all
right i'll take whatever experience i
don't know this is a this is a drug lord
battle it's been going on since the
beginning of time the only difference is
they're so powerful they've taken over
the entire world and their drugs are
legalized
so
you know they figured it out we're not
going to sell them on the streets we're
going to send our our gangs to
med school and then we're going to take
over the med schools and we're going to
train over there and we're going to put
all the doctors in one and then you
can't question anything because it all
comes from the guys now we own it all
and control it all oh wow so make sure
you keep wearing the lab coats everyone
believes you but that is this has been
going on they started drugging your kids
when they gave you adh pills adh
your child has a condition i've never
seen so many conditions in my life over
the last 15 20 years it's um
but listen
at the end of the day
um
we can talk about all we want
um
it doesn't bring out any positivity and
i keep telling everyone well now what do
you keep moving along we you got to
figure out the now why because talking
about it too is for me starting to get
boring it's like all right i get it we
know they suck all right we know we're
being taken over all right we get it
this is all a joke what are we doing now
this guy's talking about avoiding
hurricanes
by getting a shot it's clear as day
except for the robots who can't see
because they're just too in the matrix
it's not their fault now
what
that's that's what i'm waiting to hear
well my my then what i've we always say
on our show is is like when this stuff
happens
control what you can control right like
you can control your family you could
control what you do day to day you could
control whether you're going to go along
with it you could control
look if
i'm very simple right like if there's a
place that's going to tell me you have
to get vaccinated to go i'll be like
look
i've not been welcomed at parties before
that's fine i don't need to go i'm fine
you know trust me i'm not losing i'm not
losing out because i don't get to see
seven dust you know like i i
so but my point is like
that's what i tell people like take care
of what you can take care of right what
can you do you know find places that you
live around people that are like that
and that are like you mentally right
like florida's a great place right where
you could be there's every single race
and everybody lives here and the one
thing that we've all gotten along we've
all agreed with is like look we might
disagree politically in this step but
the one thing as floridians we agree
with leave us the [ __ ] alone and that's
it if you leave me alone
well you came out with something really
that we used to talk about all the time
is you can only control your own destiny
right that's it and you're a little
circle but what's
what you have to avoid
if you turn off all media
so many of the world's problems will end
immediately and what i mean by that you
know
years ago i would do a radio show and
and people like do you see what's going
on
on the other side of the world no dude
we got it
what are you gonna do this is just
another way to get you freaked out we're
getting into the boogeyman what are you
gonna do and i would say
whoa dude what are you gonna do if we go
to war
what are you gonna do what are we gonna
do
i'm 38 i'm not going to do anything
they're not going to draft call me when
they're on my front porch but in the
meantime my father's dropping a deuce in
his pants i got two kids this one's got
to go to ballet this one's got to go to
um horseback riding my wife is sick so
she over there like i don't care what's
going on in iran i don't care what
happened in minnesota and there's riots
because everyone else is all jazzed up
from an eight-minute edited film and
propaganda making people kill each other
i got things to do right here that are
way more important in life
than getting caught in the world it's
like control your world don't try to
control the world and that's the minute
people figure that out
we're going to be just fine breaking off
into little little
little villages little packs little
whatever and we
and
and just kind of
fender off
those damn screens so you're saying you
don't want people to bother you unless
you have a red dawn situation unless
yeah unless they're parallel shooting in
yeah yeah
that's fair you're right you wanna you
wanna see what are we supposed to do oh
we might have a nuclear war
okay well none of us are going to
survive so why are we getting hopped up
over it yeah
good point what do you want me to do
about it unless i see patrick swayze in
a letterman jacket outside my house with
an ar-15 i'm good to go i'll relax you
know
i mean seriously i mean that's that's
the way the bs news and that's how they
try to grab you they're just non-stop
well you better watch out for korea or
you better watch out for the middle east
or you better watch out for you like no
i gotta watch out for this animal
that i have in my house that that's
starting to eat brand new furniture i
have it done
stop stop getting involved with those
unnecessary things in life well that's
the thing i think it's because i think
you're right about like social media
it's like everybody feels now their
opinion is important it's super
important what i have to say oh oh good
what phil from boise has to say is gonna
change our international policy like
it's not you know it's not gonna do any
of that
science is cool when it's treating his
wife but clearly not what's taking care
of the safety of his fans
what a yo-yo just with her big fingers
going i can't wait to give up my
educated opinion oh my god people don't
even realize how lunacy they look by the
way i don't appreciate the fact that you
looked at me when he said i have an
animal in my house eating all my new
friends he has a new cat and it's been
not it's been a it's been it's been a
process he adopted a cat and now he
found out that the cat has feline hiv
yeah fib yeah i took in a street cat
that was living like basically by a
dumpster at a circle k
because he was so nice he's such a sweet
guy and he was like out there and i
don't know people were like yeah he got
abandoned i'm like he's my new buddy but
now it's now he's gotten too confident a
little bit too familiar in there and
that's
starting to dive bomb onto my [ __ ] on
my knick-knacks and [ __ ] scratch
things and just destroy and i'm like i
guess this is just my life now
it's my life
um so yeah let's let's actually yeah i
was gonna ask
something else i wanted to ask about the
show um because you are
launching a show now i guess you're
doing something on patreon
yes so
yeah i want to hear about this
so the patreon is
i'm really glad i did this i'm not lying
um
i've been yeah i've been dying to do a
lot of things and what now i won't say
i'm forced but now it's
given me
the kick and the push to do it so i've
been dying to do all different types of
podcasts i just didn't know how or is it
just
this subject or that subject or this
subject
and then i figured out that's just
segments whatever so
the way patreon started was i was doing
a comedy special it was coming out a
platform i said i don't want to play
places where people get boxed
the platform called me and they said ah
dude
we we can't host this special anymore
because
there's some big boys who are invested
with and i'm like i get it i get it
where should i go oh what about this
company um they're owned by
the same type of people
[Laughter]
okay well where should i go and then
finally uh came up you know some people
said um
why don't we do patreon and
i'm not gonna lie at first i went
the only reason is i know myself
i'm a 54 year old guy going patreon to
see monthly i'm like i'm not being
monthly i'm out i'm never going to be
able to get this off my bill i'm never
she's gonna keep going give me a year
from now going why am i still paying for
it
um
but what it did do
is you had to join it to see my comedy
special
and then i took it as the opportunity
well oh well now i could do start these
podcasts that i've been dying to do
forever and maybe that'll be of interest
to them and i could show every single
side of me and that is what it turned
into it's turned into
interviews like this i take i take
patreon listeners they do the um
they do the podcast
um and then i have the bruniverse
which is just me and i'll have guests
and we
and one week it's um
me talking about a heavy thing that's
happened in life a spirituality thing
and then the next week it's full-blown
conspiracy and i'm not saying i believe
it but i'd like to present to you and
i'm just like i mean it's a little weird
you tell me it's up to you and i have i
have different people chiming in on it
and
um
and so that is that and
now i'm gonna do live concerts so
yeah i'm looking forward right now right
now i'm in tampa
and tomorrow night i'm going to stream
it live on patreon so once a month
i'm going to be streaming live and so so
i had a patreon member said dude
i love being on here because i see you
don't think it's too much he goes dude
for 15 bucks i get a concert once a
month i get to listen on the podcast you
always say damn hey you go see a regular
show it's costing me
50 100 i'm doing i get to watch you as
well all right i get it you're hopped up
that's awesome and
it's allowed me to be way way more
creative and it's making me
extremely creative and i've really found
a comfortable comfort zone
on on patreon i really have i love it
it's cool yeah i mean we we use it too
and it actually really
it's a cool way to
to really connect with people that like
what you do and support what you do you
know like we we do five shows a week but
one of them is is patreon only right
yeah i know it's a little yeah it's too
many yeah we're full time give you a lot
of time baby it's a lot of content yeah
and we actually do uh our own solo shows
five days also that so we do two shows a
day each five days a week yeah i do oh
my god does 10 a.m animals i do 10 p.m
and then we do it together four to six
so it's wild but we had to get used to
patreon too because
we come from
we're showing our age here a bit but
we're a little older too so we weren't
around for the whole
subscriber based sort of things and we
were uncomfortable there's a lot of
people be like what am i just going to
beg people for money but right it's
awkward it's awkward but the but the
industry is changing it's evolving and
and it's
it's there are mass amounts of people
who are already conditioned to send in a
super chat already want to sign up on
patreon they've already got four guys
that they support on patreon so it's
it's not about like our perspective of
it it's the the younger people shit's
changing so [ __ ] that we wouldn't have
thought we would do 10 years ago it's
like look at look at come town look at
dick masterson look at who are these
podcasts there are some
like some dudes that are really killing
it on patreon because they do a good
show they do a consistent show so it's
and it's especially when you do like
like he said we do four free shows a
week so you don't have to [ __ ] sign
up for patreon to catch our show but
once a week we have our little you know
we have our little get-together for the
boys you know for the for the boys with
a couple of bucks and then we maybe get
a little spicier and we get a little
wilder and we have some put that's all i
mean so yeah
you become comfortable in it when people
you know because you have detractors
that are like oh really you asked for
money on patreon you got enough money
and it's like yeah but you get for a
show you don't have to give me any money
dude just hey man just come in the chat
say hi once in a while you don't know
it's a dime
but other people do go yo i do watch you
for free four days a week look here's
five bucks a month who cares man wait
it's not it's just it's what's happening
it's what's happening now people don't
really pay for cable anymore right you
get like the subscription service that
you want right oh i want this because
hbo max has sopranos so i want that and
and that's what that's basically what
this is it's like instead of having to
sit there and watch a channel are they
hoping your show comes on you can go oh
cool these are the people that i like
i'm gonna get exactly what i like and
without any of the filler and i mean
it's it's really it's a good model and
without having to take a commercial
every 10 minutes like on regular radio
you know it's like now now i can [ __ ]
listen to like what is essentially like
with jimbo or on the old serious but i
don't have to just cut out the middle
man i just give him the [ __ ] give him
give him the tenor instead of [ __ ]
you know what i mean like whatever it is
serious or whoever and that's that was a
great show by the way
you did a great show on there man you
you are a phenomenal
you are one of the like you are a really
good storyteller because you you you're
funny
but man you you you can venture into
some pretty kind of sad kind of deep
kind of dark [ __ ] and you kind of
navigate it in a way where you're not
like [ __ ] bumming everybody out like
you can get you know what i mean like
you can get seriously but by the end
you're not like jesus i'm [ __ ] sorry
i listened to that like you still
managed to make these like sad moments
funny and like dude the [ __ ] old
pizza man stories and all that [ __ ] dude
man i love that stuff man like you just
like you start telling a story like
nowadays we're all visual we want to
watch video we wanna and it's like i can
still listen to like some gymboree stuff
where you can just close your eyes and
be like
damn dude he's painting a goddamn
picture like you know what i mean like
you really do feel like you're there
that's how i felt on opie and anthony
you painted a picture and they would
tell these stories and even when i
wasn't on then i would listen to that
you know anthony's dying to be dirty but
he can't say the word so he he start
painting it was just so funny because
you get your own visual and i i love
doing that i love painting that picture
and other people's minds thank you uh
from your kind comprehensive yeah i
loved i loved that show that was a lot
of fun obviously if anyone should have a
podcast it's you man i mean you you mean
you you're
i've got it i was watching you
i think you were on theo vaughn and you
were telling him that was great yeah
yeah that was great we're telling him
leo's great too yeah theo rules yeah he
is you were telling a norm story and i
was in [ __ ] stitches dude i mean you
were talking
you were telling the norm story about
like your first year on snl
and uh they told you now make sure that
you know that they were asked they were
asking you do you watch oh you're a fan
of snl and you it's a press conference
yeah press conference that's what it was
it was our first press conference it did
that we were all areas yeah we're all
nervous and uh we're all lined up and
it's the first time i was like
there's a lot of media here some people
were live and
and they're like norm
they said they said the norm like norm
uh
what kind of practical jokes you got
lined up for the new cast
and
and after prepping us for like an hour
how to think what you're going to say
and
you know you're going to see the stuff
he goes
look at it
as you say we're kind of fragile jokes
[Laughter]
yeah we're getting prison raped
and raped the new cast
you want to be you want to be in
sketches oh my god
and
just i was like i can't believe he just
got away with saying that like this guy
is talking about
he just
he was
we were playing um
he he loved betting and he loved
competing and it was one night where um
you know he doesn't realize i'm from the
st from from long island and where we
were on the street all the time we
handled everything on the street and so
um we were playing football in the
hallway with a nerf football it's very
serious about 3 30 in the morning and it
was me and colin quinn versus norm and
some young intern and norm kept grabbing
me and and really just
cheating like crazy and one point i got
so pissed at him
um he he intercepted a ball because he
was holding my arms so when i f when he
caught he started running i had work
boots on i kicked him so hard
in his calf
so hard with all the vicious long island
street kid in me and i would say that's
maybe one of the hardest i've ever
laughed in my whole life because he he
went down he went ah
jesus christ
brew brewer kicked me in a goddamn cat
i said well don't cheat dick ain't no
[ __ ] cake people so you don't hold
people when they're trying to catch the
ball
oh my god billy yeah you're crazy
don't be a dick we playing are we
cheating
it was such
it was such a just so childish
it's something weird about guys dude we
have this thing in our brain when we get
super competitive just super competitive
you know angry and jealous i am at this
[ __ ] intern that has a story about
playing 3 a.m football in a hallway with
norm mcdonald jim brewer
like three giants you know like
me yeah they needed a fourth guy you're
like jesus that's a great story nobody
believes in me like shut up jerry you're
full of [ __ ] dude
swear to god yeah show me a picture
[ __ ] oh man
oh my god yeah
i wish there was more stuff like that
filmed because there's way more funny
stories
of uh
just norm behind the scenes
and we used to play a lot of his clips
and it's like we we
we always have had a very big norm sort
of like you know like we would always
play clips or sound drop here because we
love norm that was a [ __ ] rough one
dude and it just came out of nowhere
when he passed because it's like [ __ ]
that was like a patrice level one where
you're like that guy is me has when
you're talking about like
just the mileage you get out of somebody
who's made you laugh over this that guy
is [ __ ] he has made me almost burst
my pancreas a couple times in life man
and he's a very he's an acquired taste
oh yeah um
he's definitely above
the room and then when you realize
when you tapped into norm's humor
he really
there's absolutely i don't know any i
try to compare him you can't compare him
to anyone and that's what made him
so funny and amazing i mean he had his
dark moments and he had all that stuff
but
he always had an underlying stinging
view
that only he could put out there the way
he can put it out knowing and no one
could ever touch him i remember just
me him and daryl hammond and just
and you couldn't tell if he was trying
to be funny he was just funny we went to
a steak and shake after a show
he's like
yeah and he stabbed it same second you
guys hungry there
very steady cheek right and so
we go in there and um
that's like yeah we're we're at it we're
out of shape he goes what
we mean you're out of shape and he he
walks because this is
this is steak
and then a shake right i mean that's
that's the name of it it's not like
steak and we don't have shape it's a
steak
and then he goes he goes outside in the
parking lot but you can hear matt psycho
there's dank side and a shake guy
stay
and shake
baby
do you have milk
[Laughter]
do you have ice cream because yeah
there's a matter
the shaker ain't working the shaking
work of jesus it's shaking
god damn man
me and me and daryl haven't is
you know it's two in the morning we just
it's just so damn funny on that same
trip he got kicked out of the state of
iowa it was such a funny entire state of
idaho jesus christ yes
we were playing the university of iowa
and he
and they said listen no cursing
um
don't touch on uh homosexuality don't
touch on religion
and you know there's a lot of kids out
there students brought their families
well okay yeah we're gonna sign it up i
get it
dow goes up just 20 clean funny
i go up do 20 and
i think i do great
norm goes up
like he's like he's like he just woke up
and he goes
[Music]
where the [ __ ] are you at
[ __ ] isla
and then he goes right out of the gate
right out of the gate
let me ask them
if you're gay because you have no
problem if you are i mean if you're gay
that's your choice you know but if
you're gay
would you rather be the ass guy
or the dick guy because
i mean think about it you're the ass guy
you're like oh my god
jessica's around my testicles and
they're just kind of touching and kind
of hurts and he's touching my spleen and
like oh my god this is painful but if
you're the dick guy
and people are just grabbing their
families and heading up the aisles
the more he got it i mean me and barrel
is just going oh i can't believe what
i'm witnessing and the next day they
were like norm mcdonald's been kicked
out of state by the governor never to
return
um and he was on letterman the next day
talking about it was the funniest thing
i ever see in my life knowing that i
watched that whole thing go down
dude i think there was something
admirable about the fact that he
like
he he had
no respect for any of those institutions
like no that's not to say that he was
always disrespectful he wasn't
necessarily dripping with disrespect
but he had no like there was just a
certain level of like yeah you don't
have any power over me like i'll do the
gig whatever like this isn't gonna make
or break me dude i'm still gonna go home
and enjoy my life with my [ __ ]
friends and you know be happy like
there's something to be said about like
he was like that i think patrice o'neil
was like there's something to be said
about certain people that just kind of
go you don't need to like what you're
going through now where you're just kind
of like i'll do the shows i can do and
you know i got fans and they love me and
we'll meet up and we'll do stuff but i'm
not you're not making me go through a
whole [ __ ] you know you're not going
to grind me up and make sausage out of
me just so i could just so i could go
get on [ __ ] colbert for for five
minutes which is a [ __ ] dead show and
not funny anyway so like who cares like
we were saying that recently on our show
about how like oh there was a time 10 15
years ago where he and i both would have
[ __ ] probably sucked the devil's dick
to get on tv and get some [ __ ] state
to get some time on the spot and then
but it's it's turned into such a thing
where now you look at it and we're doing
all right for ourselves and you go i
don't think i'd go on one of those tv
shows if they offered now we'd be like
what's the point yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] them
like they you're not even pulling the
numbers that internet people on youtube
are they're threatened they're
threatened by rogue and that's why
they're making fun of rogan now too
because rogan is his numbers are just
annihilating all of them and they don't
understand that maybe the reason you're
not funny is this used to be a late
night comedy show and now you're
lecturing me every night yeah it's the
show every night
every night because they are paid by
their lord masters that's exactly what
it comes down to and everyone can try to
debate it and argue and say that funny
they are and part of them believe it but
part of them also know they are into
something
that's
uh they know a lot of them know exactly
what they're doing and they have sold
their souls and they know they sold
their souls and they know they're
committed to that soul because that's
hard to give up man it is hard to give
up your spot on that magazine it's hard
to give up that commercial say don't
forget tonight you get to see the big
this guy again that's a heart it's hard
to show up at a restaurant without the
hostess calling oh we're packed but not
for you mr mr celebrity mrs mrs
important and that is that's a hard
thing to give up but um i can't i can't
imagine selling my soul to do carpool
karaoke it just seems like a terrible
payoff you know
just that's me or to be in the new cats
like no thanks i'm fine i'm all right
jim no i know we hadn't i know we had an
hour man i feel bad because then you
have to go you have to go up here in a
little
no no well what i was going to say was
the platform like the two of you
rogan has been doing this a long time oh
yeah
um
you know even mark maron making his mark
and i used to i couldn't stand mark a
lot of us couldn't stand mark because he
was an [ __ ]
but
he came back
and his stick was
i used to be an [ __ ] and i'm gonna
say blah blah blah blah and i and i have
to say i felt
so happy for him because he found his
voice he found his niche and that's
where he belonged forever and boy did he
shine and he was amazing to listen to
rogan is incredible to listen to and you
could attack these people all you want
but unfortunately what has happened is
there's a billion little baby rogans
growing right now there's a baby mark
marin's growing all over the world not
just the country they're spouting up all
over the place that once the truth is
out with is it is
we the people are waking up noticing how
fake
the real television is how corny
it's being exposed how how edited and
just well-placed corny tracy morgan used
to make me laugh so hard i'm not going
to say who he used to say about it but
he would say i would say
hey man what's so-and-so like and he go
he bubble gum
i said he he he said he said he bazooka
joe
bazooka joe with the joke you know he
bubble gum jim tracy morgan
was
um
off the screen
and off the stage to this day i think
the funniest
comedian and person that i've ever been
to presents so i've never
laughed so hard with someone with their
own with the way he does man he was uh
so and that's right
yeah and that's high praise because
you've been around a lot of people you
know i mean uh i love tracy morgan i
think he's one of he is one of the
funniest people
oh yeah of course wrong when he's raw oh
he's raw i don't think there's anyone
funny and when they try to you gotta
rule oh yeah yeah sorry man hey man
thank you so much we really if you're
ever in orlando uh let us know we'll
treat you to gator bites and we'll go
shooting machine guns
i'll take on us bro thank you so much
what's the patreon what's the how do we
find it let's somebody had to say it now
the the podcast is also there's these
podcasts and then there's the bruno bird
the bruno version
podcast first visual and all that and
then it'll end up on youtube and all
that but uh thank you very much
thank you man i really appreciate it man
go go break a leg
take it easy buddy
that was great
it's awesome